six months ago I said this about Twitter
and some people thought I was crazy I
predict
Twitter's right now worth what 40 some
billion dollars can you pull up what
Twitter's worth today should I put this
on Twitter today if you can get it the
rounds are 100 million uh if you can get
in and there's not a lot of people that
are sitting on 100 million dollars
that's cash that's the challenge market
cap 38 billion dollars okay here's what
I'll tell you Twitter
ran by Elon Musk will be a trillion
dollar company within three to five
years and that's the latest which means
and by the way this is my opinion okay
this is if you do it you lose money
that's your risk this is my opinion I
think this is a trillion Auto Company
um I think that 40 goes to a trillion
that's 25x you put a million bucks
you're gonna make 25 you put 10 billion
bucks you can make 250. you put 100
Grand it's going to be two and a half
million dollar investment because if
Facebook's worth a trillion if Google's
worth a trillion if Amazon's were two if
you know I think Apple's worth three
whatever the number is this is going to
be a trillion dollar company because the
people that ran Twitter they don't know
how to make money and Elon knows how to
make money he's going to create
different ships right whether it's going
to be you want a blue chip to get rid of
the Bots 4.99 a month you want an
additional uh you know benefit to do
this 19.99 a month and you want the
ultimate it's 100 bucks a month he's
going to make money off of Twitter and
he's going to bring so many different
ideas that nobody's even thinking about
most people think Tesla is a car company
it's a battery company that's why he
doesn't like selling Tesla because he
knows Tesla is going to be a 10 trillion
dollar company and he's he knows he's
going to be the first trillionaire in
the world he's probably two to five
years away from being a trillionaire
this guy's going to be a trillionaire
we're gonna have a trillionaire within
the next 24 to 60 months but Twitter by
this guy running it I have a feeling
this thing's gonna go to the roof so
that was May 5th and by the way if I may
still be wrong but I'm going to make my
case do 10 reasons why I believe Twitter
will be a trillion dollar come company
so first of all let's get some context
here he bought the company for 44
billion dollars so if I say it's going
to be a trillion Auto Company we're
talking about 22 23x it's very very
difficult to do so but let me make my
case to you odds are on my side to be
wrong so first of all let's get some
context out there he bought the company
for 44 billion dollars a lot of people
said you overpaid for the company and to
be a trillion dollar company he needs to
23x or some number like that right it's
a big number but here are 10 reasons why
I believe it's going to be a trillion
dollar company number one so the first
point may just wrap up the whole video
here but here's what it is you ever
heard of WeChat in China it's a trillion
dollar valuation company roughly it's
Uber in one app it's conferencing it's
shopping it's venmo it's PayPal it's
Twitter it's content create YouTube
everything under one app is called
WeChat and Elon can potentially turn
Twitter into WeChat and if he does it's
a trillion out of valuation number two
if there's one thing elon's gonna figure
out how to do is how to make money by
the way let me give you an idea this
whole Twitter blew that they did 4.99 I
signed up right off the bat the
verification eight bucks a month as much
conscious people are complaining about
it they're going to get the verification
blue and what that's going to do eight
bucks a month it's going to eliminate so
many Bots all the fake people it's going
to eliminate here's the part A lot of
people are not talking to me so AOC
saying here's a place for free speech
and Free Speech wants you to pay to have
free speech eight bucks a month you know
LinkedIn the app that a lot of people
use that say very very very valuable
platform do you know how much they
charge the lowest level membership at
LinkedIn is 29.99 a month it's premium
career premium business is 59 let me
goes 79 then it goes 119 a month and
some people pay for it some people don't
pay for it what if he created that
option on Twitter for different tiers
that other people pay and why is he
doing this to raise money and get more
money coming in because Point number
three he wants to bring content creators
to start creating content on Twitter so
imagine how many people who are creating
content right now on tick tock on
Instagram on YouTube but on Twitter when
you create content you get paid nothing
what if now you can start making money
on Twitter and they add ads in front of
it and now you're making money so
content creators are like man I'm going
to take this clip I'm going to put it on
Twitter as well I'm going to create
content specifically for Twitter he's
making money so he can pay content
creators so more eyeballs come in so
user goes up so valuation goes up
because capitalism Works in a way where
you got to make money and Elon knows how
to make money put number four Tic Tac
formerly known as musically is one
president away from being banned in
America because both Democrats
Republicans Independents don't trust
Tick Tock just like India banned Tick
Tock in all of India 1.2 1.4 billion
people America could be next to band
Tick Tock and if they do people gonna
lose their minds a lot of them but
they're going to take their talents
elsewhere just like they took their
talents when they left a Vine wait Point
number five he's bringing Vine back and
Vine is like Tick Tock so will
tick-tockers move to vine hey what
happens if that happens here you go
again WeChat Tick Tock Twitter YouTube
Everything combined valuation goes up
that's why he's bringing a Vine back
because it's going to attract The
Tick-Tock Talent when Tick-Tock is
banned in America point number six
Facebook is getting destroyed right now
it's just the reality of it they lost
market cap roughly 800 billion dollars
that is not a mistake they were a
trillion dollar 60 billion Auto Company
meaning 1.06 one trillion dollar company
in 2021 they're 250 billion dollar
company right now some number like that
Zuck lost a hundred billion dollars of
his net worth why is Facebook getting
crushed they chose meta they spent
roughly 31 billion dollars just trying
to develop meta the Facebook audience is
going all over the place they don't
trust what happened with FBI involvement
all this other stuff people again on
both sides do not trust Facebook that
audience will go somewhere and they're
most likely going to go and find a home
with Twitter because more Americans
trust Elon Musk than they do Zuckerberg
that Q score is out there you can find
it to see how people feel about both the
level of people that trust musk is much
harder than the amount of people that
trust Zuckerberg and nowadays that
matters a lot Point number seven there's
a whole audience of free speech that are
afraid of creating content on YouTube on
Facebook just the other day guys were
tagging me on Instagram valuetainment
and they were sending me screenshots
saying do you know if I right now tag
value team in Facebook says this and
Instagram says this and free speech and
I'm worried what's gonna happen we're
Free Soil those people who are afraid of
free speech there's one place they're
going to feel very comfortable going no
matter how much they trash them it's
going to be Twitter the Free Speech
Community has officially found a home as
of right now and it's called Twitter not
Facebook not YouTube definitely not Tick
Tock it's called Twitter and they're all
flocking over to Twitter again more
users more valuation more profits eight
cutting Workforce this guy knows what
he's doing it comes onto Twitter he just
announced I think even today he
announced fifty percent of people
getting emails there's like a class
action lawsuit right now to sue Elon
because Twitter is just suddenly firing
these guys it's 3750 people that are
getting fired here today my own
speculation is he's firing everybody on
Twitter because he wants to move out of
Silicon Valley to move Twitter
headquarters to believe in Texas or
maybe Florida do not be surprised if
Twitter moves this hasn't even be talked
about by anybody I just think they move
they may move out of state and that's
why he's letting people go to go to an
easier regulated State like Texas
imagine if that were to happen people
would lose their minds in Silicon Valley
if that would have happened this guy
knows how to save money and he knows how
to run a tight shop and he's going to
saving a lot of money when you let go of
3 750 people you run on tighter margins
which means bigger profit margins and
which means he's got more money to
invest into things that actually helps
the company grow that's the next part
Point number nine do you know this guy
when he bought Twitter what's the first
thing he did one of the first things he
did he brought Tesla Engineers to look
at Twitter's technology let me get this
straight the same Engineers that created
a computer that became a car that even
AOC bot and she drives a Tesla she a
socialist loves his car the capitalist
can you imagine this love affair
he brought 50 Engineers from Tesla to
say hey can
I keep the technology on Twitter to see
how we can make it better he brought
Brains Brains that built another
trillion dollar company market cap I
think it peaked at a trillion I don't
know where it's at right now 680 650 700
billion dollar company will you bring
those Minds to look at the engine to see
what Twitter's got you know what's going
to happen they're just going to figure
out a way to make it better
and last but not least like this is
going to be a trillion dollar company
you ready because of a guy named Elon
Musk Elon Musk was part of PayPal Mafia
Elon Musk built SpaceX into 125 billion
dollar company Elon Musk Bill Tesla into
a trillionado company right now with the
market being done it's at 650 or so
Iran's resume is the best resume when it
comes down to increasing Market Capital
company today in America no one's got a
better resume than there's a lot of good
resumes he's got the best resume as a
capitalist and a capitalist increased
valuation and money coming in so Elon at
the helm right now he called himself a
bunch of different things Chief customer
service officer Chief this chief that he
knows how to troll people he's having
fun he's talking to everybody he's the
best customer service rep in the world
today he's responding back to customers
at a 250 billion hour net worth how many
people you know at that level are
responding back to customer service this
guy is doing it he's unique he's
different he's not like everybody else
this is the situation where when you
have the horse and a jockey who do you
bet on you bet on the jockey matter of
fact I made a video about this maybe
four years ago when the whole question
was should we invest into Tesla when the
company was worth I don't know 50
billion 40 billion and and the
conversation I made in this video is you
got to bet on the jock if you've not
seen that video click over here number
two
if you want to take a quiz to see what
you're driven by because musk is driven
by Madness when you take this quiz
you'll realize there's four different
things everybody is driven by one is
advancement one is a selfish desires
that you have individual recognition the
other one is purpose and the other one
is madness if you haven't taken this
quiz yet to find out what drives you
click here to take that quiz with that
being said have a good one everybody
take care bye-bye
foreign